i have a regret that i
am not president because i think there's
so much opportunity build real
relationships
even with people with whom you
vehemently disagree you'll not only be
happier
you will be more successful steve jobs
speaking at stanford was asked by a
young man
how can i be more like you how can i
become like you
and jobs famously answered think
different
success and happiness do not result from
a single thing
the result from an accumulation of
thousands of little things
need motivation what's a top 10 with a
believe nation
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are
you are the most ambitious person in
your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best
joe biden and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one find your
inner strength do you feel jesus could
have beaten hillary
i've yes
but it would have been an incredibly
difficult race
and i have nothing but friendship for
hillary i have a regret
that i am not president because i think
there's so
much opportunity i think america is so
incredibly well positioned um but i
don't regret the decision i made because
it was the right decision for my family
oprah no woman or man should announce
the running for president unless they
can answer two questions
one do they truly believe they're the
most qualified person for that moment
i believed i was but was i prepared to
be able to give my whole heart
my whole soul and all my attention to
the endeavor
and i knew i wasn't were you still
broken
my family was broken i was broken i
still find myself like talking about my
bow
my my son who died
i sometimes find myself say something
and i can't handle it i start to
i break down um so it's not like it's it
ever
the pain ever goes away but
what did what i do is i look at my
grandson his son
i see him i look at my granddaughter i
see her
and i know he's still here i know he's
still
he's still with me rule number two build
real relationships
resist the temptation
of your generation to let network
become a verb that saps the personal
away
that blinds you to the person right in
front of you blinds you to their hopes
their fears and their burdens
build real relationships even with
people with whom you vehemently disagree
you'll not only be happier
you will be more successful rule number
three
find your sweet spot like all of you
when i graduated i felt a similar
pressure what will i
do
[Music]
but the script was written find the best
job
with the most prestigious law firm you
can be in a position
to advance to make good money
become a partner that's what i did
i landed a job because of the help of my
professors with one of the most
prestigious law firms in my state one of
the oldest in my state
but the problem was
as i strode across the stage in 1968
the world had changed
dr king had been assassinated
there were riots throughout america
a significant part of my hometown of
bloomington delaware
was burned to the ground we became the
only city
since reconstruction to be occupied by
the military
for nine months
national guard in every corner with
drawn bayonets
state troopers patrolling the
neighborhood not city cops
and i was home with a prestigious job
because wasn't that was i supposed to do
wasn't that what i expected to do
but six months later i realized that
wasn't what i was supposed to do
and to the surprise of the senior
partners of my law firm i walked out of
a federal courtroom
caddy corner across what they call
rodney square the center of town
into the basement of the building on the
far corner and i walked into the public
defender's office
and i asked for a job remember the guy
holding directing the office and his
name was franny kearns he said aren't
you with
and i said yes he said you're making a
big mistake
[Music]
but like many of your parents
i was lucky just in time
i learned early on
what i wanted to do what made me the
happiest
family faith being engaged in the public
affairs
that gripped my generation when i
graduated
the civil rights movement environmental
movement the women's movement
ending a bitterly divisive war
[Music]
in vietnam
now it's your turn it's your time
time to attempt to find
that sweet spot where success
and happiness intersect
and it's not easy
some of you will go into uh and on to
powerful law firms on wall street
government service prosecutors office
public defenders some of you will take
the knowledge
and be successful entrepreneurs
representing and represent non-profits
some of you will serve in the military
some of you go back to your home
countries
and risk risk your lives
for the rule of law
but all of you will have one thing in
common
you'll all have to figure out how to
balance
success happiness and ambition
rule number four have a vision what i
was struck by i read that ever since you
were a little boy
you were a boy with a vision that you
had a picture in your head
of the kind of man that you wanted to be
did you live up to your own expectations
did you fulfill the
vision or exceed the vision i
by and large um uh
believed that i have uh
ended up being the man i wanted to be
but it wasn't in terms of accomplishment
it was because people usually translate
that into you know
the young guy i knew i wanted to be
senator and new wanted to be president
but that wasn't true what was true was i
want to live up to my parents
expectation
and i wanted to be that person that
my mother met my mother's standard being
defined by my courage
i wanted to be that person who who was
no matter what happened just got back up
and kept going i wanted to be that
person who was there and loyal
to people who were loyal to him i wanted
to be there i wanted to be that guy
who was knew what was worth losing over
also if you want to build more
confidence the sign says it can take up
to 254 days
of consecutive action to successfully
build
a habit so i've created a free program
for you where every day
for 254 days i will send you an unlisted
video to your email
absolutely free to help you build your
confidence the link to join is in the
description below
who am i no really who am i
what do i care about and the answers to
those questions have resulted in the
woman who stands before you today
when you pull it off it's great same
thing in real estate
you go against the tide people are
selling you're buying
the tide changes you have to explain why
you're the right person
to lead and above all you have to know
your numbers rule number five
invest in yourself when i
did my financial disclosure as vice
president the first time
the washington post said quote it's
probable
no man has entered the office of vice
president assumed the office of vice
president
with fewer assets than joe biden
i hope they were talking financial
assets
and then there was all this discussion
about why i had no money
i'll tell you why i had no money four
years of penn
three years of syracuse four years at
georgetown
three years at yale two years at tulane
two years at penn and now a
granddaughter at penn
i was asked why i wore a pen tie my
answer is i
earned it
rule number six have compassion and i
mean this sincerely there's nothing
particularly unique about me
with regard to resilience and compassion
there are countless thousands of people
maybe some in the audience who'd suffer
through
personal losses similar to mine or much
worse
with much less support to help them get
through it
and much less reason to want to get
through it
it's not all that difficult folks to be
compassionate
when you've been the beneficiary of
compassion in your lowest moments
not only from your family but from your
friends and total strangers
because when you know how much it meant
to you
you know how much it mattered
it's not hard to be compassionate rule
number seven
earn trust i've met an awful lot of
successful people i've literally met
every major world leader in the last 42
years
personally met them
so many others
people who by any standard
are considered success but i've observed
as i've gotten to know many of them a
significant number of them are not happy
i've worked with eight presidents
only 13 senators have served longer than
me in the entirety of american history
industry leaders the cycons of silicon
valley
high-powered lawyers doctors nurses
teachers social workers
and i made several basic observations
that i hope will help you
those who i observe to achieve both
success
and happiness those who balance
life and career those who found purpose
and fulfillment they all
understood that there's no silver bullet
no single formula no reductive list
they all seem to understand that success
and happiness
do not result from a single thing
the result from an accumulation of
thousands of little things
with the common feature
that they built their character
first the and happy people i've come to
know understand that a good life
at its core is about being personal
being engaged it's being there for a
friend or colleague
when they sustained an injury in an
accident remembering to congratulate
them
on a marriage or birth
being available to them as they're going
through personal loss or failure
it's about loving somebody more than you
love yourself
it seems to all get down too personal
that's the stuff that fosters
relationships
and the only stuff that breeds trust
in everything you do in life
the way you earn trust
and i mean earn trust rule number eight
think different steve jobs speaking at
stanford was asked by a young man how
can i be more like you how can i become
like you
and jobs famously answered think
different
you cannot think different in a nation
where you cannot breathe free you cannot
think different in a nation
where you are unable to challenge
orthodoxy because
change only comes from challenging
orthodoxy
and what you've learned at this great
university and throughout this system
is to challenge orthodoxy
that's why today our economy is still
two and a half times bigger than any
other in the world our workers are three
times as productive as any worker in the
world
high-tech manufacturing is coming back
to united states
and your generation has already joined
the ranks of those
who are leading the world in innovation
and job creation
and we're about to enter an era of
breathtaking change in progress
we're on the cusp of innovations
that will literally change the world and
some of the people who i
had the honor of being honored with
today with the greece can tell you more
about this than i can because they're
already
changing the world we live in rule
number nine stand up for your beliefs
you know guys uh particularly you women
every one of your parents uh
every one of your parents when they
dropped you off on the first day of
class or
put you on a plane or a train and kissed
you goodbye
they had great expectations for you but
along
with those expectations expectations for
real
was a nagging nagging fear
will you be all right not just will he
be all right
in terms of your grades are you going to
be okay
[Music]
they may not have known the statistics
but they know when they dropped you off
that there is you'd think the last place
you'd have to worry
about dropping your beautiful son or
daughter off would be
on a college campus should be the safest
place in the world
and the fact of the matter is
uh that fear is real
and for too many parents that uh
that fear uh has been realized
or will be realized you know when i
wrote the violence against women act
back in 1989 when i drafted it
and i literally drafted it i mean it's
not
because there wasn't there wasn't much
of a
support at the time as a matter of fact
not a single
national women's organization all of
whom support me not a single one
supported the legislation
at the outset because of two reasons one
they thought that
it would take away from other issues
more pressing
choice gender equality
equal pay and i think people although
they cared about it
thought maybe there's not much we can do
about it i think that was the
i think that was the underlying
subconscious feeling
and uh um and uh
the fact is that uh we finally
we finally after all of a whole range of
hearings and
a lot of time we finally got
got support i remember i called a
meeting of all the
women's and civil rights organizations
in my office i was chairman of the thing
called the judiciary committee
and i was still pushing and there were
objections being offered on the margins
well you didn't want to increase the
penalties for rape you didn't want to do
and finally ellie shmeel who i love and
was a friend of mine was head of the
national organization where women said
literally not a joke she said what are
we doing
why don't we support this guy why don't
we support this guy
and everything began to change
everything began to change
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is have fun
[Music]
my name is joe biden i love ice cream
i'm an ice cream guys ice cream down
that way
y'all gotta eat this ice cream
[Music]
south carolina is going to determine who
the next president united states going
to be
you really are you're the ones that sent
bill clinton to the presidency and
you're the ones that sent barack obama
the presidency
and i have a simple proposition here i'm
here to ask you for your help
where i come from you don't get far
unless you ask
my name's joe biden i'm a democratic
candidate for the united states senate
look me over if you like we see help out
if not both the other by
give me a look though okay now i've got
a special bonus clip that i think you're
gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your plan of action that
you're going to execute this week
to make some immediate momentum happen
when you just get
motivated and watch a video you have a
35
chance of following through that's what
the science says but
when you write down what time what day
what place you're actually going to
execute when you create the plan
you have a 91 chance of following
through
and i want that for you and when you
commit to people publicly
you increase your chances even more of
actually doing it
so i want to know what your single
biggest takeaway from this video was
and your specific plan of action
to actually get the result you're after
let me know put it down in the comments
below because
i want to celebrate you my generation
heard the same voices of doom and
despair
that your generation hears today
american decline
america's lost its way wither america
what those voices do not and did not
understand
as in both instances yours and mine we
graduated into a world that had changed
in the world of william butler yates
writing about his
ireland in a poem called easter sunday
1916 he said
all's changed changed utterly
a terrible beauty has been born
old answers the policies of the previous
generation
that had served my generation so well
had little applicability to the world
and to which i was graduating
on the eve of my graduation dr king had
been assassinated
the vietnam war was raging in the shadow
of my convention robert kennedy was
assassinated
our political system was in chaos
but as we strode across that stage to
receive our diplomas
to a person we were absolutely confident
that the naysayers were wrong and that
there were significant
possibilities available to us
we ended the war in vietnam we entered
the nuclear stalemate
the soviet union secured civil rights
fundamentally altered women's rights for
the better
began an environmental movement that's
far from finished
ushered in an information age that
shrunk the world beyond recognition and
in the process
laid the foundation for a period of
technological innovation
that generated the world's strongest
economy in the 70s 80s and 90s
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there